Film Courage: Well congratulations on the nomination
tonight! Charles Randolph [The Big Short/Bombshell Movie] Oh thank you very much.
What music we were listening to while
you were writing [for The Big Short]? Charles: Ah I don't listen to
music when I write. Yeah I'm not I um I
often write in public spaces so you know
there's enough distraction there yeah
and you know you want to shift gears
emotionally and the music doesn't always
help you do that I mean you can get you
into a mood but but then it can kind of
get you too deeply so come on so I'm not
yeah i'm not a big music my right person
i'm very curious about that so you
riding a lot of spaces are you the
typical for much wiser well you know i
wrote this one in an office i was living
in Greenwich Village in time I live
upstate New York now and so I sort of
rotate from one small town to the next
you know coffee shops I'm trying that
for a while which I've done that before
I wrote my first script in this building
as a matter of fact yeah but so I'd
scared varies depends on what's going on
in my life what me because I have
rounded out if I'm trying like maybe we
ride anywhere you right where the mood
and tempo match the theme of the film
whatever you know you know what's
actually interesting no no I don't think
I don't think it's the actual speed of
the tip of what I'm doing really
reflects the emotional content may seem
very much
it's weirdly it's more immersive than
that right i mean you sort of you
shouldn't become so deeply enmeshed in
that particular scene that yeah 3 years
the actual writing part of it you know
the actual running part is different
than the epic the ideation this is a
pretentious race but via the creation of
the ideas right so they happen in two
different phases and kind of getting
more emotion of a specific scenes a
little more important in the sort of
rewriting process and the actual
creation process I find all that's not
always the case with usually tonight
your favorite scene is there a scene
that just really stands out where you're
super proud of it or there's a
conformational charge oh gosh you know I
think Adam and I are both really proud
of the the Ginga see you know it's sort
of a nice combination of our skill set
we're there they're all learning about
the tray hello um well you know the book
is such a lovely book and so helpful
that it's a little music you know we use
so much of its shockingly little does is
not in the book there's maybe six pages
which is a little jaunt in Florida that
the guys take but by large we almost you
know we almost used everything and so i
have to say i'm sort of i'm very proud
of a 42 section because obviously i sort
of we made that up at up whole cloth but
but yeah the Ginga game scene for me is
is it just the rhythm of it and the
degree of improv the actors brought to
it
and some of instantly interstitial stuff
I answer that everything kind of comes
together in medicine when do you do your
best writing I right in the afternoons
yeah I tend to lean it worthless before
lunch yeah so I'll start over lunch sort
of writing making notes and stuff and
then I'll go to about six or seven and
nine
if you find yourself procrastinating how
do you get back on track by the suppose
you start surfing the internet yeah yeah
thats just that simple I look at my bank
statements and you know or my little
kids hungry faces and then it reminds me
of yeah I need to work so yeah no there
is no great strategy for going for a
graduation because the strategies
themselves can become forms of
procrastination but yeah you know I
actually think that sometimes a little
bit of that is good for us you know
getting away from something moving away
getting your mind on something else I
mean I think the internet is probably
not the best form of procrastination
because it's consuming its mcluhan would
argue it's sort of a hot media engages
but there are other forms of
procrastination like driving for example
it I
and last question do you find you it
will get a high off across the nation
and a deadline you know a lot of people
yeah I mean you know exactly what you
mean uh no I may be I'm just too
terrified of them you know III I don't
know that I get a high of that I mean I
get a high when something works really
well and beautifully it's really
exciting and that happens you know once
every three or four weeks and you sort
of live off that emotional rush from
something that sort of thing is
remarkable and special that you love and
your work but no I find that I find
pressure doesn't really help I don't
produce my best work
excellent thank you very much you're
welcome thanks